- I can do this.
(cheek making flapping noise)
(upbeat music)
- I regret to say that
the first love letter
I ever wrote was written
after I had received
my first love letter and
then that's what inspired me
to write love letters.
Me and my friend love, which is fitting,
would write each other letters.
She wrote me a lot more
letters than I wrote her
but, we would just little things, like,
"I love you today."
Or, "I hope you're having a great day."
Or, "Miss you."
Or, "Just remember you're mine."
Heart, smiley face or whatever.
It was, you know, cute
little things like that.
Just reminders.
I love candles.
- But what does it smell like?
- But this candle, it's like a light blue
which means it's probably sweet
and I don't like sweet candles.
- Wait, you--
- I want like--
- Hint of lavender?
- Like a dark rum.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Smell, like, you know?
- More of like a--
- Woodsy.
I've met someone on Instagram
and like I developed this
ostensibly intimate relationship
with them and then turns out
they weren't who they were.
As catfishing does.
- I think maybe once or
twice they were in the script
but I say whoa, whoa, whoa
all the time. (laughing)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, okay, relax.
First job was working as a model
at eight years old out of Miami
and it was for a Macey's catalog.
I was a little Macey's
baby in the New York Times,
14 years ago. (laughing)
And then I like dry it
and I just shake it.
Whenever we're doing stuff like this,
so I can talk to you guys,
there's like this spray,
this sea salt spray.
Is that what it is?
Sea salt spray?
That like makes it look like
I just got out the ocean.
(ocean waves lapping)
It's all fake.
First thing you do when you wake up?
I go right back to sleep,
it's the first thing I do.
I cannot wake up and be like, alright,
today's gonna be fantastic.
I wake up and I go, no.
Not yet.
Shantaram by Gregory David Roberts.
The whole book is very poetic
and it's a journey from
deep diving into the abyss
and then coming back
from it and transcending
and changing and learning
and it's a beautiful read.
- Do you think you're an extrovert?
- I charge introvertedly and then I'm like
(snapping fingers)
super outgoing.
- Let it out.
- He really has a great
grasp on his personality,
as we can tell.